the verdict did not come as a surprise  alexei navalny was found guilty of  defrauding a timber firm  while working as an unpaid advisor to  the provincial governor in kirov  five years ago  having examined the case the court has  established that navalny is guilty of a  crime against russia  back in december 2011 navalny was one of  the leading figures behind protest  rallies that broke out in the wake of  national elections  who has the power he called out to  demonstrators  navalny became a well-known figure for  exposing political corruption  his plan was to run for mayor of moscow  later this year and to stand for  president in 2018  they claim the rule of law is being  applied  but it's who's pulling the strings  but nobody will admit that  navalny's lawyers have said they'll  appeal the verdict  but the chances of the decision being  overturned are  painfully slim